[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في مدينه ريد ام اكس في النمسا
في الثالث والعشرين من ديسمبر عام
1981 ولعائله من اصول مصريه ولد الدكتور
فريد حافظ وكان بالامكان ان يعيش حياه
هانئه كاوروبي صالح لكن التزامه وايمانه
بهويته ورغبته بالتعبير عن حقه في الحياه
كمسلم ملتزم ينال حقوقه الاساسيه كامله في
التعبير كما ينالها الاخرون حتى من
الاقليات غير الاوروبيه والمسيحيه تصادمت
مع واقع التخويف من الاسلام ومحاوله تصنيف
المنتمين له بصوره سلبيه وحرمته من تلك
الحياه مضطره شيئا فشيئا ان يتخصص في بحث
ودراسه الاسلام بوفوبيا ومواجهه اثارها
واعمالها في المجتمعات الاوروبيه
والمفارقه ان فريد يرى الامر احيانا
مواجهه للاسلام كدين وللمنتمين له وليس
للاسلامويين او الناشطين او السياسيين كما
يقول حصل فريد حافظ على درجه الم في
العلوم السياسيه من جامعه فيينا عام 2006
ثم نال درجه الدكتوراه في ذات التخصص من
الجامعه نفسها عام 2010 عمل في جامعه
سالزبورغ قسم العلوم السياسيه وكذلك
كاستاذ زائر لبرنامج في جامعه كاليفورنيا
وكباحث زائر في جامعه كولومبيا في مدينه
نيويورك عام 2014 وهو المحرر المؤسس
للكتاب السنوي الالماني الانجليزيه
لدراسات الاسلام وفوبيا منذ عام 2010
والمحرر المشارك للتقرير الاوروبي عن
الاسلام بوفوبيا السنوي منذ عام 2015
والذي يغطي اكثر من خمسه وعشرين دوله
اوروبيه وهو كذلك حائز على جائزه برونو
كرويسكي المرموقه لعام 2010 عن الكتاب
السياسي للعام عن مختاراته في مجال
الاسلام وفوبيا في النمسا تتركز اهتمامات
الدكتور فريد حافظ الاساسيه على الاسلام
وفوبيا كما ذكرنا والتي تتنامى في اوروبا
ودراسه الاحز والتيارات اليمنيه الاخذه
بالاتساع ويشرف على جمعيه الشباب المسلمين
في النمسا وكان احد الذين اقتحمت الشرطه
منازلهم في عمليه الاقصر الشهيره التي تمت
على يد اجهزه الامن النمساويه في عام 2020
ما ادى الى خروجه من البلاد بعد عام منها
ليغادر الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قبل ان يبرا من الاتهامات التي وجهت اليه
البروفيسور النمساوي المسلم فريد حافظ ضيف
المقابله هذا المساء فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك يا دكتور سعيد بوجودك في المقابله
المحارب الشاب محارب الاسلام وفوبيا في في
اوروبا والذي دفع ثمنا كبيرا نتيجه هذه
الحرب اريد اولا ان اتعرف على فريد حافظ
وانت نصف عربي نصف النمساوي
النمساوي كمواطن ولكن اصولك مصريه
اولا اشكرك على الاستضافه هنا انه لا شرف
كبير حقا ان اكون في برنامجك حسنا اعني
للتحدث قليلا عن نفسي لقد ولدت في النمسا
لام بيضاء من النمسا واب من شمال افريقيا
يعتبر نفسه قوميا عربيا افريقيقيا
نعم
الهويه ولكنه كذلك
كويس من المهاجرين القدامى
كما تعلم لقد هاجر في اواخر السبعينيات
اعتقد انه كانك كثير من الناس الذين
اصيبوا بالاحباط بسبب الوضع الاقتصادي في
مصر في ذلك الوقت ومن ثم حاولوا البحث عن
حياتنا افضل انت داخلك ماذا تشعر فريد
تشعر بانتماء كبير للعالم العربي ولا
بانتمائك الاوروبي اكثر
بالنسبه لكثير من الناس اعتقد انها تشكل
مشكله تتعلق بماهيته هويتك كما تعلم لاكون
صريحا لقد واجهت هذه المشكله عندما كنت
صغيرا ما هو انتمائي ومن الواضح انه
بولاده في النمسا وتنشئه الاجتماعيه في
النمسا تشكل لدي ارتباط كبير بها لانني
اشعر من الناحيه الثقافيه انني انحدر من
هناك لكن في الوقت نفسه كما تعلم اعتقد
انني قد تجاوزت هذه الاسئله ايضا واشعر
انني في بلدي في العديد من الاماكن لا
اريد تضييق نطقهويتي انا انسان هذه هي
هويتي
كل كل هؤلاء العرب الذين عاشوا في في
المهجر دراستك كانت طبيعيه اعتياديه
في جامعه فيينا حيث كنت اعيش طوال الاعوام
العشرين الماضيه ثم انتقلت الى جامع والان
انا هنا في الولايات المتحده
لماذا درست العلوم السياسي لماذا اخترت
العلوم السياسي هذا سؤال جيد في الواقع
كما تعلمون بالعوده الى التسعينيات عندما
كنت صغيرا كنت ناشطا ضمن الشباب الاشتراكي
ثم انشانا الشباب المسلمين شعرت ان
الجاليه المسلمه التي تعيش في النمسا كثير
منها بل غالبيتها في الواقع من العمال
الفقراء لذلك كان لدينا عدد قليل من
الاشخاص الذين يمكنهم التحدث بالنيابه عنا
لم اكن اشعر بانني كنت ممثلا حقا لذلك
اعتقدت اننا بحاجه الى اشخاص يعرفون النظ
السياسي ويمكنهم التحدث لصالح مستقبلنا
متى اسستم منظمه الشباب المسلم
نعم كنت ابلغ حينها من العمر 15 عاما كنا
شباب يعني من سن 15 ادركته اولا هويتك
كمسلم وادركت ان هناك اشكاليه
اكبر مصادر الهام في الواقع شخصيه غربيه
وهي مالكوم اكس القادم من الولايات
المتحده وهذه هي الطريقه التي تم بها
تسهيسي ولكن ايضا اصبحت اكثر تفهما لموضوع
العرق والدين وقد اكتسبت من سيره مالكم x
نوعا من المفردات حول كيفيه التفكير
والتحدث عن هذه القضايا
ماذا يعني ان تكون ان تكون مسلما امر
مفهوم ماذا يعني ان تكون مسلما اوروبيا
شعبا في تلك الفتره ماذا كان يعني لك هذا
الامر ما التحديات المرتبطه فيه في منتصف
التسعينيات قبل احداث الح اكثر من سبتمبر
كانت الامور واسهل بكثير اليس كذلك لذا
كما تعلم كنا نفكر فيما يقوم به المسلمون
في جميع انحاء العالم وكنا متفائلين جدا
باننا نستطيع صناعه مستقبل افضل شعارنا
بشكل طبيعي اننا في وطننا في النمسا في
اوروبا شعرنا باننا اوروبيون مرحب بهم
راينا ان هناك خصوما وكان هناك اشخاص لا
يرغبون في افساح المجال لنا لكن في
المقابل كانت هناك ايضا اغلبيه الناس على
استعداد لتقديم الدعم لنا وقد كان هذا هو
شعور السائد لان احد اسباب قيامنا في ذلك
الوقت بتاسيس الشباب النمساوي المسلم هو
اننا لم نكن راضين حقا عن المنظمات
الاسلاميه الموجوده في محيطنا كان الكثير
منها في زمن التسعينيات وما زالت تتبع اما
تركيا او الدول العربيه قلنا مصيرنا هنا
لذلك نريد ان نفعل شيئا لمستقبلينا وكانت
ذلك بمثابه نقد للبنيه الاساسيه الاسلاميه
القائمه ولهذا منظمه الشباب حتى هنا الامر
يبدو اعتياديا بالنسبه لشاب مسلم من اصول
عربيه اوروبي نمساوي بالكامل لكنك انخرطت
فيما بعد في حرب
الاسلاميه في هذه العمليه التي يتم
صناعتها في اوروبا ما الذي ادخلك اعمق فيه
في هذه القضيه وفي الصراعات الناتجه عنها
يعني
يحصد فرص جيده ان يعيش بشكل طبيعي لماذا
خفت هذا المسار الصعب
انه امر مثير للاهتمام لانه من ناحيه كانت
النمسا ولفتره طويله واحده من اكثر
البلدان تسامحا مع المسلمين هذه حقيقه
كانوا مرحبين جدا النمسا هي واحده من دول
اوروبا الغربيه القليله التي احترفت
بالاسلام بشكل قانوني كدين منذ عام 2012
وما حدث في عام 2005 هو ان اليمين المتطرف
اختار بشكل متعمد مهاجمه المسلمين وجعلها
صوره نمطيه رئيسيه وانهم العدو العام
الرئيسي في ذلك الوقت لم تكن بقيه الاحزاب
السياسيه في صفهم ولكن هذا تغير لاحقا
لذلك عندما بدات في اجراء بحث حول ظاهره
الاسلام فوبيا كان الامر يختصر على اليمين
المتطرف ولا يشمل المجتمع باسره هذا اولا
الامر الاخر هو انني قادم من الريف اصلا
صحيح فقد نشات في بلطه صغيره جدا
الشمال الى حدود المانيا كانت تلك المنطقه
قريبه من مسقط راس ادولف هتلر كان هذا هو
موطن معاداه الساميه الفجيره لذلك عندما
كنت طالبا درست عن معاداه الساميه وعندما
بدات ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا في الانتشار
وشاهدت ذلك هذا ما حدث هذا ما يحدث حاليا
انها تمثل معااده السميه لقد تغير الشخص
لكن الصور النمطيه واحده اليس كذلك لذلك
من الدراسات الخاصه بمعدات السميع دخلت
مجال الدراسات ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا وكان
احد الاسباب الرئيسيه في ذلك الوقت لهذا
انه لم يكن هناك من يمثلنا استعرضت جميع
الباحثين المعادين للساميه في المقابل
كانت هناك قله قليله جدا ممن يتحدثون ايضا
عن ظاهره الاسلاموفوبيا لذلك شعرت ان هذا
هو الوقت المناسب للتعبير علنا ولهذا
السبب بدات في اجراء دراسات حول الظاهره
الاسلاموفوبيا في البدايه عندما كانت هذه
المشكله تقتصر على اليمين المتطرف فقط
اولا وقبل كل شيء كنت من المشاهير لقد
حصلت على جوائز عن كتب الاولى وتم الدعوه
بشكل متكرر للقيام باعلانات تلفزيونيه
طالما ان هذه كانت مشكله اليمين المتطرف
فقط لكن المشكله اتسعت عندما تبنت احزاب
الوسط الموجوده في السلطه بالكامل اجنده
اليمين المتطرف فريد الجو بارد هنا سنناقش
كثير من القضايا ماذا تفعل انا اقابلك في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ماذا تفعل هنا
في امريكا
الاتصال بالولايات المتحده لفتره طويله
والسبب هو اولا وقبل كل شيء ان ارثى
العنصريه والعبوديه ايضا اعطى الولايات
المتحده القدره على الحديث عن العنصريه
نحن نفتقر الى تلك القدره في اوروبا في
اوروبا لا نملك الكلمات والمصداقيه للحديث
حقا عن هذه القضايا وهذا بحق هو السبب
الرئيسي الذي يجعلني اشعر فكريا هنا بانني
في وطني اكثر مما اشعر بذلك في قاره
اوروبا
وبسبب كل ما اشاهده في الولايات المتحده
فان الناس يفهمونني ولا يتوجب علي ان اشرح
لهم ابجديات العنصريه بالعوده الى اوروبا
سينكر الناس وجود هذه المشكله لذا كما
تعلمون بعد حدوث عمليه الاقصر اصبح الامر
جليا بالنسبه لي
الان اتباحث في جورج تاون وباحث ايضا انا
استاذ الدراسات الدوليه في كليه ويليامز
في مبادره بريدج في جامعه جورج تاون للبحث
في ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا الحياه في اوروبا
الان بالنسبه لاكاديمي ومثقف وصاحب قضيه
اصبحت اصعب
بالتاكيد وليس في الاونه الاخيره فقط لقد
بدات بالفعل منذ عامين في تقرير ظاهره
الاسلام فوبيا في اوروبا الذي شاركت في
تحريره لدينا مؤلفون تعرضوا للهجوم من قبل
وزراء خارجيه بلدانهم لكتابتهم ذلك
التقرير لدينا اشخاص اتصلت بهم وزاره
الداخليه لاخبارهم قائلين اذا اردتم
الاستمرار في الحصول على الاموال فلا
تقوموا بهذا العمل لدينا اناس تمت مهاجمته
من قبل اليمين المتطرف انا سعيد جدا
بوجودك الدكتور فريد في المقابله لدينا
قضايا كثيره حول صناعه الاسلام وفوبيا حيث
حول مواجهتها حول تفكيكه وحول ما يجري كله
بشكل عام في اوروبا وفي العالم بشكل اخر
وكرس عادته بوجودك مرحبا بك في المقابله
اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]
بالتزامن مع بروز تيار اليمين في اوروبا
تصاعد الغناء للمسلمين او الاسلام فوبيا
وهي في معناها المبسط تعني تنميط المسلمين
المهاجرين واتهامهم بانهم غير مندمجين في
مجتمعاتهم وبانهم يشكلون بؤرا للارهاب
وساهمت احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر في ربط
الاسلام بالعرب وتجاهل حقيقه وجود ملايين
المسلمين الاوروبيين والامريكيين وبكونه
دينا عالميا يعتنقه منتمون الى اعراق
وثقافات ومناطق الجغرافيه مختلفه
وعلى امتداد العقدين الماضيين ازداد نمو
الظاهره وكانت البدايه من حملات اخذت
تتكثف تدريجيا وخطابات عامه نشرت الخوف من
الاسلام ووجدت صداها من خلال حوادث
استهدفت مسلمين ومساجد وشخصيات اسلاميه
وشيئا فشيئا بدات تتشكل لغه عالميه حاولت
ربط بالارهاب وبمرور الوقت تحولت هذه
اللغه الى منتجات دوليه وجدت طريقها عبر
وسائل الاعلام والثقافه الشعبيه ولم تقتصر
معاداه الاسلام على الخطابات السياسيه
فتدخلت وسائل الاعلام العالميه لصناعه
محتوى مسائل وباتت الاساءه للمقدسات اداه
تتبناها وسائل الاعلام الغربيه ضمن
اجندتها
اهلا بكم مع مجددا مشاهدين الكرام في
المقابله ضيفنا الليله الدكتور فريد حافظ
الباحث الزائر في جامعه جورج تاون وكذلك
في جامعه مساجس مرحبا بك دكتور
ومباشره نذهب للقضيه الرئيسيه التي ارتبطت
بك شخصيا في السنوات الماضيه قضيه مواجهه
الاسلام وفوبيا وصعود اليمين
المتطرف في اوروبا والحاله العنصريه
المناهضه للمسلمين عمليه الاقصر في النمسا
كانت كانت لحظه مفصليه حينما واجهت فيها
الدوله مجموعه كبيره من المسلمين بحجه
انهم اسلاميين وانهم ناشطين وانهم اخوان
مسلمين وكنت احد المستهدفين في هذه
العمليه
برايك عن ماذا تعبر عمليه الاقصر تحديدا
وقبل كل شيء شكرا جزيلا على استضافه هنا
في برنامجك
حقا انه سؤال مهم للغايه واخشى انه ليس
لدينا جميع الاجابات على هذا السؤال
بالذات لكن اسمحوا لي ان اقدم لكم بعض
الاساليب المختلفه لمحاوله الاجابه على
السؤال اعتقد انه من الواضح في النمسا ان
القياده السياسيه الجديده التي كانت تحت
قياده سيبستيان كورتز من الحزب الديمقراطي
المسيحي المحافظ كانت تستهدف المسلمين على
وجه التحديد وانها تبنت بشكل اساسي جميع
المزاعم السياسيه التي جاء السابقا من حزب
اقصى اليمين المتطرف لذلك قاموا بتطبيق
حظر الحجاب واغلق المساجد وتم الغاء كل
هذه الاجراءات بشكل اساسي من قبل المحاكم
بما في ذلك المحكمه الدستوريه في النمسا
وهذا ما حدث مع عمليه الاقصر فقد تقرر ان
تكون عمليه الاقصر مداهمه غير قانونيه
الاسلاميه ضد الايديولوجيا الاسلاميه هل
تمت فرق بين الامرين
انه سؤال مهم جدا واسمحوا لي ان اقدم لكم
اجابه من وجهه نظر تاريخيه بحته لم تكن
الامبراطوريات الاستعماريه عند استعمرت
البلدان الاسلاميه تعادل المسلمين جميعا
سيقولون دائما ان هناك صالحين معاصرين
وتعريف الصالحين لا يتعلق بالدين الذي
يعتنقونه بل بالاحرى ما اذا كانوا
متعاونين مع السلطه ام لا
المسلم الجيد المتعاون معنا والمسلم السيء
هو الذي يختلف معنا هذا بالضبط ما نراه في
هذه الايام الامر لا يتعلق بالاسلام حقا
اعتقد ان كثيرا منهم لا يهتم حتى بالاسلام
حقا لكن السؤال هو هل تساند مؤسسات السلطه
ام انك تطالب بحقوق متساويه واعتقد ان هذا
ينطبق على اشخاص مثل ممن يتحدون ويتحدون
السياسات التمييزيه فيتعرضون للهجوم لذلك
اعتقد ان هذا هو احد الامور التي توضع على
المحك هنا حسنا هناك الكثير من المنظمات
الاسلاميه في جميع انحاء اوروبا لا تتم
مهاجمتها ولا التعرض لها من قبل هذه
السلطات والسبب في ذلك هو انهم يتعاونون
مع من هم في السلطه ببساطه شديده
باعتقادك هذه المواجهه الاوروبيه مع
المسلمين في في بلدان اوروبا الرئيسيه
المانيا فرنسا بريطانيا النمسا وما الى
ذلك لها علاقه بالمسلمين وكونهم خطر ام
لها علاقه بالدوله الاوروبيه نفسها
واشكاليات تواجهها الدوله الاوروبيه
والانظمه الاوروبيه الحديثه
اعتقد انه يتعلق كثيرا بازمه المجتمعات
الغربيه لا علاقه له بالمسلمين ودون ان
ابدو فيلسوفا بشكل كبير لكنني دائما ما
اقتبس من الفيلسوف الفرنسي الشهير الذي
قال لو لم يكن اليهودي موجودا لكان
المعادل السامي قد اخترعه لا علاقه لقضيه
ظاهره الاسلاموفوبيا بواقع المسلمين الذين
يعيشون في اوروبا الامر يتعلق برمته
بالعنصريين تجاه المسلمين اذا تاملت على
سبيل المثال لماذا تعتبر النمسا وفرنسا في
الماضي القريب من بين اكثر الانظمه عنفا
تجاه المجتمعات المسلمه اعتقد ان احد
الاسباب هو ان هذه البلدان فيها اعلى نسبه
من المسلمين الذين يعيشون هناك في النمسا
تبلغ النسبه تسعه في المئه وفرنسا تقدر
النسبه ب 10% وتلك هي الدول التي قامت
بقمع المنظمات غير الحكوم الاسلاميه والتي
استهدفت بشكل صريح تلك المنظمات التي
تراقب ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا هؤلاء هم
الاكثر شراسه لا يوجد اجماعنا الان في
اوروبا على ان هذا هو الطريق للمضي قدما
يمكننا ان نرى في الماضي القريب ايضا ان
هناك دولا كانت تقاوم نهج صدام الحضاره
هذا
تعرف هذه المساله الدكتور هذه المساله في
غايه الاهميه لانه نحن يبدو ان المسلمين
في سجن
ودائما يطرحون السؤال ماذا يجب ان نفعل
حتى يقبلون بنا حتى نبدو متحضرين اكثر حتى
نبدو مدنيين اكثر
حينما نفهم المساله بشكل على نحو صحيح
تتغير ماذا يجب ان يفعلوا هم حتى تسير
الحياه بشكل صحيح هناك فرق بين بين
الامرين
حسنا اذا فهمت سؤالك بشكل صحيح فاعتقد ان
القضيه المطروحه هنا نعتقده انه اذا كانت
مشكله ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا هذه لا علاقه
لها بالمسلمين لانك اذا سالت اشخاصا عن
حياتهم اليوميه فستجد انهم يتعيشون بسلام
كما تعلم تكمن القضيه في انك اذا نظرت على
سبيل المثال في السويد او الدنمارك حيث
يوجد ايضا الكثير من سياسات الدوله
العنيفه والمعاديه للاسلام والتي تستهدف
على سبيل المثال انشاء مدارس اسلاميه خاصه
او ما شابه ذلك هذا شيء يخبرنا عن سبب
قبول مؤسسات السلطه بوجود الكثير من مدارس
الكاثوليك او البروتستانت الخاصه لكن اذا
كان لديك اثنان ثلاث اربع خمس مدارس
اسلاميه خاصه ذات اداء جيد فانهم يرون
انها تمثل تهديدا واعتقد ان احد الاسباب
هو انك اذا نظرت الى تاريخ هجره الكثير من
المسلمين خصوصا الى قاره اوروبا ضع
المملكه المتحده جانبا لانها حاله
استثنائيه لكن بالنسبه لبقيه اوروبا على
مدى عقود كان المسلمون جزءا من العمال
الفقراء الاشخاص الذين هاجروا بشكل افضل
لقد اصبحوا اساتذه ويطالبون بحقوق متساويه
ويقومون بانشاء مدارس مثل المدارس المخصصه
للكاثوليك والبروتستانت واليهود ايضا
والان نرى ان هناك جزءا بسيطا لكنه قوي في
بلدان مثل المانيا والنمسا يقولون لا نرغب
بذلك ولا نرغب في وجود مشاركه اسلاميه على
قدم المساواه في مجتمعاتنا ومن هنا تنبع
المشكله
الا يبدو الامر طبيعيا بمعنى اوروبا تعرف
نفسها على انها اوروبا المسيحيه يعني وان
كانت علمانيه ليبراليه لكن بحدود يعني
فرنسا بلد العلمانيه هي بلد مسيحي صرف كل
الاثار كل الاسماء كل كل المصادر الثقافيه
اساسيه مرتبطه بالديانه المسيحيه لديها
تصورها الخاص على الالمانيه ولكن اوروبا
تريد ان تقول اننا ان هذه اوروبا المسيحيه
وبالتالي وجود المسلمين فيها يشكل خطر على
هويته مثل ما فعلت باليهود يعني
المجازر والمحارق التي ارتكبت بحق اليهود
كانت بسبب رغبه بوجود اوروبا مسيحيه نقيه
وبالتالي تم تصدير اسرائيل الى الى العالم
العربي تم تصدير اليهود خارج اوروبا اي
بمعنى الا يبدو طبيعيا ان اوروبا تريد ان
تكون مسيحيه فقط لا تريد ان تكون اسلاميه
لا تريد ان ترى الحجاب لا تريد ان ترى
المساجد لا تريد ان ترى مسلمين كثر تريد
ان يكونوا موجودين على الهامش لكن لا
يكونوا جزء رئيسي في الصوره الاوروبيه
نعم هناك ارث لاستعماري طويل لهذا لكن في
الوقت نفسه بعد عام 19
45 بعد نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه بعد
انتهاء قتل سته ملايين يهودي كان هناك
اجماع اجماع سياسي قائل لا لحدوث ذلك
مطلقا مره اخرى لا نريد ان يحدث هذا مره
اخرى لا نريد ان يكون لدينا اقصاء عرقي
لاقليه معينه سواء كانت عرقيه او دينيه او
ايا كان الان هذا هو الاجماع السياسي وهو
ما يعني ان الاجماع السياسي يحتضن التنوع
والديمقراطيه والمساواه لا يهم اذا كان
لديك نظام اكثر علمانيه كما هو الحال في
فرنسا او في دول اخرى اكثر تحفظا حيث يلعب
الدين دور الرئيسي لدى الشعب الان من
الواضح دعونا نسترجع مثال المدعي العام
الذي قال حسنا المحكمه العليا هذه هيئه
علمانيه انه يمثل هذا المنظور المسيحي
الاصولي لكن بعد ذلك لديك المحكمه العليا
التي قالت حسنا هناك مساواه ولا شيء مما
يفعله هؤلاء الاشخاص بمن فيهم انا هو
جريمه جنائيه اليس كذلك اذا فهي حريتهم في
تنظيم انفسهم انها حريه المشاركه هل تمت
تضارب داخل اوروبا نفسها داخل القوه
السياسيه القوه الثقافيه القوه المجتمعيه
يعني اختلاف حول مساله ادانه الحاله
الاسلاميه او او ثمه اتفاق برايك
اعتقد انها قضيه متنازع عليها بشده لذا
اعتقد ان ما نراه الان هو نقاش داخل دوائر
السلطه حول كيفيه التعامل مع هذا واعني ما
اراه هو ان هناك اجزاء من المعسكر السياسي
الاكثر تحفظا اختارت بوضوح اجنده اليمين
المتطرفه العنصريه للغايه وهم يقدمون
انفسهم على انهم المنقذون لاوروبا
المسيحيه البيضاء ثم لديك الكثير من
المعسكر العلماني المعسكر اليساري المنقسم
على نفسه
قد يقول احد المعسكرات بناء على افكارنا
وقيم الديمقراطيه والمساواه نريد منح
هؤلاء الاشخاص مساحه للمشاركه والاخر يقول
حسنا لكنه متدينون والدين يمثل مشكله
بالنسبه لنا فنحن نحارب الكنيسه منذ مئات
السنين لذلك علينا ان نواصل هذه المعركه
ضد المسلمين الذين يشكلون خطرا على دولتنا
العلمانيه الليبراليه لذلك هناك هذه
المناهج المختلفه مشكله مع كل ذلك هي انه
بغض النظر عن المنصب الذي تشغله فان
الفكره في حد ذاتها ان المسلمين يشكلون
تهديدا للمجتمعات الاوروبيه اعتقد انه
خيال عنصري
بادي ذي بدء ليس كل المسلمين اسلاميين
اليس كذلك معظم المسلمين الذين يتعرضون
للهجوم هنا هم اناس عاديون
ما الفارق هل هل يدرك الاوروبيون او يعني
هل يصنع ون فارق بين المسلم والاسلام
هل يصنعون فارقا بين المسلم الطبيعي
والاسلامي لانه يتحدثون عن يسار اسلامي
يتحدثون عن اسلام سياسي يتحدثون عن
اسلامويه يتحدثون عن اسلام متطرف هل
يفرقون بين هذا الامر ام يصنعون هذا الامر
ليكون اطارا عاما لجميع المسلمين اعتقد ان
المشكله تكمن هنا اليس كذلك اذا تاملت على
سبيل المثال عمليه الاقصر في اليوم الاول
بعد المداهمه عندما احضروا الناس الاقسام
الشرطه وطرحوا عليهم اسئله فان الاسئله لم
تكن عن العنف ولم تكن الاسئله حول وجهات
النظر السياسيه كانت الاسئله مثل هل تسمح
لابنتك بالغناء هل تجبرت زوجتك على ارتداء
الحجاب سمعت دكتور هذه الشهادات في الفيلم
الوثائقي ما خفي اعظم والذي تناول هذه
العمليه وكان عملا لافتا
برايك لماذا يسال
المتهمون هذه الاسئله هل تصلي الفجر
عائلتك زوجتك تصلي معك هل تسمح لابنتك
بالزواج في سنه 9 سنوات لم يكن تحقيقا
مرتبط باتهامات او بقضايا لماذا سئلت مثل
هذه الاسئله برايك
ضباط الشرطه الذين شاركوا في هذا تم
تدريبهم من قبل اشخاص يؤمنون بهذا بالضبط
يؤمنون بان الاسلام يعد بحد ذاته مشكله
وليس الاسلامويه وان كل شكل من اشكال
الاسلام يمثل تهديدا للمجتمع الاوروبي
واسمحوا لي ان اقدم لكم مثالا واحدا
المستشارون الرئيسيون الباحثون الرئيسيون
الذين كانوا وراء هذه الانواع من الافكار
يحاجون بان التطرف اللام فيه بمعنى اخر
الاسلامويه اخطر من التطرف العنيف
وبعباره اخرى فان الاسلام السياسي اخطر من
القاعده والاخوان المسلمين اخطر من
القاعده وما تمكنوا من القيام به هو ان
يحاجوا ان كل شخص ناشط في السياسه في
مجتمع في خلفيه اسلاميه يجب ان يكون من
الاخوان المسلمين
وبنظره من هذا النوع تجد هذه الانواع من
الاسئله تطرح على المتهمين بالارهاب
حقا هذا هو الادعاء بان المتهمين في عمليه
الاقصر كانوا جميعا يمولون الارهاب وهم
جزء من منظومه ارهابيه لماذا لان الفكره
لا تفرق بين الارهاب من جهه والاسلام من
جهه اخرى مسلم
لماذا لا يكون هناك مشكله مع مع
الديمقراطيون
المسيحيين وتكون هناك مشكله مع
الديمقراطيين الاسلاميين خاصه انهم
مواطنين اوروبيين يعني لماذا لا يحق
للسياسي المسلم الاوروبي ان يكون اسلاميا
بشكل علني وان يتبنى رؤيه الاسلاميه مثل
الديمقراطي المسيحي الا ان الديمقراطيين
المسيحيين هم من في السلطان اما المسلمون
الذين يشاركون فليس لديهم قوه اقتصاديه او
سياسيه وبالتالي يمكن فعل اي شيء معهم لقد
كنت انتقد الكثير من هذه الاجراءات ليس
فقط لان المسلمين هم الضحايا الضعفاء لهذا
انهم اول ضحايا هذه الموجه الاستبداديه
لماذا لانهم لا يستطيعون الدفاع عن انفسهم
بشكل جيد لذا بمجرد ان تبدا بذلك فانك
توسع نظامك الاستبداد وهذا ما اعتقد هو
الخطر العام المتمثل الذي يسير جنبا الى
جمع ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا انه ليس تهديدا
للمجتمع المسلم فحسب بل انه يمثل تعديدا
في نهايه المطاف لجميع المجتمعات
الاوروبيه اذا اصبح هذا النوع من السياسه
امرا طبيعيا
رياح تنضح بالعنصريه هب العقد الاخير على
القاره العجوز مقترنا بصعود احزاب يمينيه
في غير بلد اوروبي ليكون مؤشرا دالا على
داء الاستعلاء والشعور بالتفوق المستفعل
في مجتمعاتها ومن فرنسا الى ايطاليا في
بولندا والسويد والنمسا وهولندا وهنغاريا
برزت احزاب تتبنى خطابا شعبويا بل وازاح
بعضها احزاب ظلت لعقود متربعه على قمه هرم
السياسه في دولها تعتمد الاحزاب اليمينيه
برنامجا يزدحم باحاديث التهديدات العرقيه
والثقافيه من مجموعات دخيله على المجتمع
ضد مجموعه اصيله بحسب تعبير تلك الاحزاب
وادبياتها ومن ثم فهي تعارض الهجره حفاظا
على نقاء العرق وحمايه للهويه الوطنيه
لا يقف الامر عند هذا الحد اذ يرفض تيار
اليمين فكره التنوع ويقف بالمرصاد لمبدا
حصول اصحاب الثقافات الاخر على حقوقهم
كامله داخل المجتمعات التي يقيمون فيها
واحكاما لغلق الدائره تنتهج الجماعات
اليمنيه في الغرب نمطا دينيا متحيزا فيعد
اعضائها انفسهم مدافعين عن الدين المسيحي
ويتذرعون بالحفاظ على القيم المسيحيه في
الصراعات التي يثيرونها مع الاديان الاخرى
وفي النمسا حيث نشات الدكتور فريد حافظ
تولى زمام السلطه نهايه عام 2017 ائتلاف
يميني من حزبي الشعب والحريه حيث طفق
الائتلاف يتخذ سلسله من الاجراءات التي
ضيقت على الاقليات العرقيه والدينيه بلغت
الامور ذروتها مع اطلاق السلطات النمساويه
في نوفمبر من عام 2020 عمليه الاقصر
الامنيه التي شملت اربع ولايات اقدمت
القوات المشاركه فيها على مداهمه عشرات
المنازل والمقر لمواطنين مسلمين وجمعيات
اسلاميه بحجه مواجهه الارهاب قبل ان تعود
وسائل اعلام النمساويه بعد نحو عامين
وتؤكد ان الحمله كانت بدوافع سياسيه
وبتحريض من دول عربيه
اريد ان ان اخوض الان في في تخصصك وفي
اهتمامك في مواجهتك للاسلام وفوبيا انت
عضو هيئات ومنظمات تهتم بهذا الامر
واستهدفت في عمليه الاقصر في النمسا لهذا
الدور بهذا السبب كيف صنعت كيف تصنع
ظاهره الاسلام وفوبيا في اوروبا في اي
مرحله الان هي من مراحلها اعتقد اننا
بالتاكيد عند نقطه تحول مفصلي اذا تحدثنا
عن ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا المؤسسيه اعني
اولا وقبل كل شيء اوروبا ليست كلها
متشابهه اليس كذلك عندما بدات في اعداد
وكتابه تقرير ظاهره الاسلاموفوبيا في
اوروبا غطينا حتى الان ومنذ سبع سنوات
اربعين دوله في كل عام مرارا وتكرارا نرى
ان هناك تغييرات جديده يمكننا ان نتلمس
توجهات جديده في بعض البلدان الان من
الواضح انه في شرق اوروبا بولندا والمجر
ورومانيا وبلغاريا
في الكثير من هذه البلدان حيث لا يوجد
تاريخيا سكان اصليون مسلمون وحيث عدد
المسلمين صغير جدا كما تعلمون انها ليست
فوبيا ان الوضع مختلف كما تعلم تجد القاده
السياسيين يوظفون هذا البعد خصوصا بعد عام
2015 عندما كان اللاجئون قادمين من سوريا
والعراق لكن الامر ليس له علاقه بالمؤسسه
لا يتعلق الامر كثيرا بالطريقه المؤسسيه
في الحياه اليوميه انه خطاب سياسي
يستخدمونهم في اوروبا الغربيه حيث يوجد
عدد اكبر من المسلمين فان الصوره مختلفه
اذا ما نراه هناك خصوصا في تلك البلدان
مجددا التي تحكمها بشكل اساسي احزاب
يمينيه وسطيه واحزاب مسيحيه محافظه في
كثير من الاحيان نشهد كل هذه الاجراءات
كعمليه الاقصر ومدهمات اخرى تحدث كما هو
الحال في فرنسا كما تعلمون انها اكثر من
كون مقدمه من المعسكر الليبرالي او
المعسكر اليميني الوسطي وينعكس هذا ايضا
على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي في البرلمان
الاوروبي غالبيه اعضاء المفوضيه الاوروبيه
من الديمقراطيين الاشتراكيين الذين لديهم
حق ابداء الراي فان المحرك الرئيسي لهم هو
اليمين الوسطي لاعطائك مثالا واحدا فقط في
الماضي كان للمفوضيه الاوروبيه شخص مسؤول
عن محاربه جرائم الكراهيه ضد المسلمين هذا
العمل متوقف منذ اكثر من عام ونصف حسنا
هذا يخبرنا بماذا انهم لا يهتمون بهذا
الامر لذلك هناك جهل بطبيعه المشكله السبب
في اننا بدانا في المقام الاول باصدار هذا
التقرير عن ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا في اوروبا
هو اظهار ان هذه مشكله انظر لدينا الارقام
ولدينا الاحصائيات عليك ان تهتم بذلك عليك
ان تفكر في هذا هذا الامر وثيق الصله ليس
فقط بالمسلمين بل بالجميع من الاكثر في
مواجهه
المسلمين بشكل عام بين الدول الاوروبيه
والحكومات الاوروبيه من القائد من الذي
يعمم النموذج والافكار لك امين
من وجهه نظر لديك مجمعه التفكير التي تدعم
سياسات الصقور المتشدده والسياسات
الخارجيه وفي الوقت نفسه تنظر الى
المسلمين على انهم مصدر تهديد نرى ان
هؤلاء الباحثين من مجمعات التفكير يتم
استخدامهم من قبل حكومات اوروبيه مختلفه
لاقناع صناع القرار ووزاره الداخليه
ووزراء العدل حتى يتمكنوا بعد ذلك من
تنفيذ هذا النوع من السياسات اعتقد نعم
هناك اجزاء من المعسكر السياسي المحافظ
ليس كلهم بل بعضهم يعتبرون انفسهم منقذين
لاوروبا المسيحيه البيضاء لذلك اعتقد ان
هذا هو المكان الذي تاتي منه هذه المنظمه
الخطيره اذا تاملنا ما حدث مؤخرا في
النمسا ولماذا حدث ذلك يمكننا ان نرى انها
ليست فكره النمساويه بحدها لذلك كانت هناك
مداوله متبادله بين مجمعات التفكير
الالمانيه
من القائد من بين الحكومات
من بين الحكومات الذي يتصدر هذه فرنسا
النمسا المانيا من الاكثر يعني انشغالا في
هذه القضيه
اعتقد ان فرنسا هي الاكثر عنفا في المانيا
خصوصا قبل هذه الحكومه الحاليه ظل
المحافظون في السلطه لمده 16 عاما لقد
نفذوا الكثير ولكن بصوره اكثر خفيه لذلك
استهدفت بشكل خاص منظمات المجتمع المدني
الاسلاميه ولكن ليس بشكل صاخب ضد المسلمين
كما كان الحال على سبيل المثال في النمسا
لذلك اعتقد ان هناك سياقات اقليميه تختلف
اختلافا كبيرا لكنني ساجزم ان هؤلاء
وخصوصا الاصدقاء النمساويين هم حاليا في
طليعه هذا الاتجاه
في صناعه الاسلام وفوبيا
ما هي الحجج المستخدمه ما هي المواد خلينا
نقول مستخدمه لتنميه هذه الصناعه حتى تصبح
ماده للسياسيين ماده للمثقفين للجمهور
العام لن تعرف ربما بنهايه دول ديمقراطيه
فتريد ان تحشد جماهيريه ماذا يستخدمون
لتنميه الاسلام
سؤال مهم للغايه لانني اعتقد ان هناك
اختلافا ما بين الجمهور العام وصانعي
السياسات لانه بالنسبه للجمهور العام ولا
سيما بعد الحادي عشر من سبتمبر هناك فكره
عامه مفادها ان المسلمين يشكلون تهديدا
فهم عنيفون وهم متخلفون كما تعلم اصبح هذا
هو التيار السائد فاذا سالت الناس ما هو
الاسلام بالنسبه لك سوف يقولون لك انه
اضطهاد المراه انه العنف وهل المجرم حسنا
لدينا هذه الصوره العامه السلبيه جدا وهذا
شيء واحد لكن بالنسبه لصانعي السياسات
هناك فرق لان ما اخبرتهم به مجمعات
التفكير وهؤلاء الباحثون هو انظروا ان
المسلمين لديهم اجنده سريه يتحدثون معك
بهذه الطريقه لكن ما يريدونه هو شيء اخر
وكذلك هم يريدون اسلمت الدول بان يصبحوا
جزءا لا يتجزا من كل المؤسسات السياسيه
لذلك هناك نظريه مؤامره ضخمه تحاك وهذا
بالضبط ما كانت تدور حوله عمليه الاقصر
كما تعلم وساعطيك فقط ارتباطا تاريخيا
مهما هنا على ما اعتقد انه مشابه جدا لما
كان لدينا مع معاداه الساميه قبل مئه عام
لان هذه كانت الفكره كانت هناك فكره
يهوديه الدوله القوميه الاوروبيه كانت
تهديد هو انه لدينا يهود اردوكس لكن حتى
اولئك الذين ينتمون الى الحزب الاشتراكي
الديمقراطي فهم اكثر خطوره من البقيه لذلك
هناك شك في ان المسلمين واليهود في الماضي
لا يمكن ان يصبح مواطنين مخلصين وهذه
واحده من الافكار الاساسيه لهذه المؤامره
ولماذا يسهل عليهم القول ان الجميع من
الاخوان المسلمين هو السبب هو ان الراي
العام لا يجد اي فرق بين القاعده والاخوان
المسلمين لم يتم اخباره لماذا لماذا تكون
تهمه ان يكون الاوروبي من الاخوان
المسلمين يعني في عالمنا العربي نفهم هذا
الامر لانه لا يوجد ديمقراطيه لكن في
اوروبا الديمقراطيه لماذا تكون مشكله ان
يكون
نمساويا او المانيا من الاخوان المسلمين
لا يوجد حديث متباين حول هذا الموضوع كما
يمكنك ان تقول بغض النظر عن الطريقه التي
ترى فيها الاخوان المسلمين واذا كنت
تنتقدهم فلا يزال لديهم الحق في فعل ما
يريدون القيام به معنى انهم ليسوا اناسا
عنيفين صحيح لكن في الوقت نفسه ما الذي
يجعل الامر سهلا عليهم عن السياق النمساوي
وقالوا انهم اسلام سياسي في فرنسا قالوا
هذه النزعه الانفصاليه الاسلاميه في
المانيا يقولون انها اسلامويه الشرعيه
تستخدم كل هذه المصطلحات المختلفه اساسا
لتاطير هؤلاء المسلمين الناشطين في
المجتمع حتى لو كانوا يكرهون وينتقدون
الاخوان المسلمين لاحظت ان تم التحول في
مساله مواجهه الاسلام والمسلمين في اوروبا
في الاول في السابق كانت تهمه العنف
القاعده واحداث سبتمبر وما الى ذلك ثم
ظهرت مساله الاندماج ان المسلمين يهددون
فكره الاندماج وان المسلمين لديهم ثقافه
متفرده ومختلفه عن الاوروبيين وبالتالي
هناك تهديد الاندماج اصبح اليوم هو القضيه
الرئيسيه في مواجهه المسلمين وفي الاسلام
وفوبيا وهذا الامر يبدو صحيحا يعني يعني
المسلمين لا يريدون ان يندمجوا بشكل كامل
مع القيم الاوروبيه
اعطيكم مثالا واحدا لقد ولدت في النمسا
والدته النمساويه بيضاء نشات كاكاثوليكي
كل ما لدي من تنشئه اجتماعيه وثقافيه
ساجزم انها نمساويه ما هو وكيف نحدد
الاندماج مثلا ان اكون استاذا في العلوم
السياسيه واقوم بالتدريس
لكنك فريد لا تمثل معظم المسلمين
الاوروبيين يعني هم يتحدثون عن فئه
غالبه ما زالت محتفظه بهويتها المحليه كما
جاءت سواء من المغرب العربي من مصر من من
بلاد الشام من اي بلد عربي مسلم انهم
محتفظين بشكل كامل بثقافتهم انا ليس لدي
مشكله هم يطرحون هذه المشكله انه هؤلاء لا
يريدون الاندماج في المجتمعات الاوروبيه
وفق القيم الاوروبيه القيم التي يرون يعني
يرون وجوب سيادتها
اعتقد ان السؤال الدائم هو ما هو معيار
الاندماج لدينا في الكثير من البلدان
الاوروبيه مسيحيون ارثوذكس يقدمون الوعظه
بلغتهم الوطنيه الخاصه بهم لدينا كاثوليك
يصلون بالاسبانيه في كنيستهم المشكله من
الواضح انها تكمن كما تعلم اثناء وجودك
المجتمع المسيحي الارثوذكسي او حتى دعنا
نقول المجتمع القبطي المصري الذي يعظ
باللغه العربيه انت لا تعتبره معضله لكن
عندما يتعلق الامر بالمسلمين فانت تثير
مشكله كبيره انهم يستخدمون لغه مختلفه
التركيه او العربيه او ايا كان كما تعلم
هذه ليست طريقه عادله لمعالجه الامراض لذا
اعتقد ان المشكله التي نواجهها هنا حقا هي
لماذا يتم اعتبار المسلم من اشكاليه في
المقام الاول بينما الاخرون ليس كذلك وهذا
يوضح لنا ان هناك طريقه مختلفه لكيفيه
التعامل مع مجتمعات مختلفه انا حقا اعتقد
اعتقادا راسخا ان العنصريه تتعلق بالسلطه
للعنصريه واقصاء الاخرين وظيفه وتتمثل
المهمه كانك طالما انك تعتبر الناس معضله
وام منشغلون بالدفاع عن انفسهم فلا يمكنهم
ان يعيشوا حياه كريمه وينشئ مؤسسات ويكون
قادرين على العمل بنجاح وان يكونوا اعضاء
المشاركين في المجتمع وهذا ما نراه هنا
دكتور خليني اسالك هذا السؤال اي اسلام
تريده اوروبا اليوم واي مسلمين تريد على
وجه التحديد عشان نفهم اوروبا يعني يعني
اي اسلام تريد واي مسلمين تريد
ان كانت تريد طبعا
مره اخرى لا توجد اجابه عامه على ذلك لان
اصحاب المصلحه المختلفه لديهم وجوهات نظر
مختلفه لكن نعم اعتقد ان بعض الاصوليين قد
يجادلون باننا لا نريد الاسلام على
الاطلاق سيقول الاخرون حسنا طالما انهم لا
يتحدون مؤسسات السلطه فلا باس دعهم يفعلون
ما يريدون وايضا لو كانوا اكثر تخلفا واقل
مشاركه لكان ذلك افضل لانهم لن يتحدون ثم
هناك من يقول انك تستطيع ان تكون ما تريد
اعتقد اننا حقا في هذه الحقبه من الوقت في
اوروبا يوجد سؤال يجب على اوروبا ان تطرحه
على نفسها هل ارغب في القبول والاحتراف
ودعم التعدديه في مجتمعنا ام لا هذا سؤال
للاوروبي في الاول كان كان مواجهه الاسلام
فوبيا يجد صدى بمعنى انه حينما يقوم
امثالك بالتشكيك بالاجراءات بمواجهتها
بالاحتكام الى الديمقراطيه كان الامر يعني
يبدو مؤثرا بعد ذلك يبدو ان هناك حرب ضد
امثالك انه لا هؤلاء يستخدمون يعني
يستخدمون الامر ايدولوجيا لاعاقه اعاقه
الامر وبالتالي بدات هناك مواجهه شرسه مع
من ينتقدون الاسلام وفوبيا ماذا يتعرض له
الباحثون
الناشطون امثال دكتور فريد حافظ في في
اوروبا نتيجه موقفهم ماذا يمكننا ان نرى
ذلك جيدا في فرنسا اي ماذا حدث في فرنسا
صرح ايمانويل ماكرون وحكومته بشكل اساسي
قائلين كما تعلمون نحن المصابون بالعمل
عرقي نحن مجتمع تجاوز العرقيه لا اريد ان
ياتي اي اكاديمي ويتحدث عن دراسات ما بعد
الاستعمار والدراسات العنصريه فهذا يقسم
مجتمعنا كانت تلك هي رساله الحكومه
الفرنسيه ومن ثم فانما اعتبروه ارهابا هو
الذي ينتقد بشكل اساسي ظاهره الاسلام
فوبيا فاذا فعلت هذا فانت تعد ارهابيا
كانت هذه هي المحاججه القائمه في المحكمه
ولكنهم ولكن مع ذلك هذه هي مؤسسات السلطه
السياسيه التي تدفع بهذا الاتجاه في حاله
كما تعلمون مع تقرير ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا
في اوروبا الذي اصدرته فقد شاهدت ان بعضا
من الموظفين قد تعرضوا للهجوم من قبل
وزراء خارجيتهم وقد تم الاتصال ببعضهم من
قبل وزاره الداخليه وتعرضوا للترهيب سبب
مجيء الى الولايات المتحده هو انني امتلك
هنا حريه للتحدث وحريه اكاديميه
وصلنا الى الحلقه اريد ان اسالك الان
كمسلم اوروبي كمسلم نمساوي
بماذا تطمح له فيما يتعلق باوروبا هل هل
هل تعتقد انه ثمه قطيعه كامله بمعنى
يكون الهدف النهائي للعيش في الولايات
المتحده او العوده للعالم الاسلامي او
العربي اذا تحسنت الامور ام ثم حلم يتعلق
بك وبكم كمسلمين اوروبيين
مازلت متفائلا بوجود اشخاص يريدون الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيه والمساواه وايضا الكفاح من
اجل الحريه الاكاديميه
اعتقد ان احد الاسباب الرئيسيه لحدوث
عمليه الاقصر او لماذا في فرنسا يمكن ان
يحدث هذا للعديد من المنظمات غير الحكوميه
المسلمه
هو انهم ضعفاء سياسيا ولا احد يريد حقا
تبني قضيتهم هم المجتمع الاكثر تهميشا
لذلك من الصعب على اي شخص ان يدافع عنهم
يجب ان يكون لديك الكثير من الشجاعه من
اجل القيام بذلك وهذا ليس ما نراه في
النمسا اذا نظرنا الى جميع القرارات
الصادره عن المحاكم وفي حاله النمسا فمن
الواضح انها تدافع عن الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه انهم لا يريدون ان تجرف موجه
استبداديه النمسا لكن السؤال الموجه لهم
هل يريدون اعطاء مساحه للمسلمين كمواطنين
متساويين ام لا عليهم ان يجيبوا على هذا
السؤال
السؤال الاخير
شخصي لماذا يعني اقحم فريد حافظ نفسه في
اتون هذه المعركه الكبرى التي لا يبدو
انها ستنتهي لماذا لم يعني وهو باحث متميز
استاذ في العلوم السياسيه وجمع بارز وحصلت
على الجوائز لماذا قررت ان تخوض هذه
المعركه
بكل هذه القوه اعتقد ان ذلك بدافع الكرامه
الانسانيه
يمكننا الاستمرار في السماح للمسلمين
بالعيش في مجتمعهم دون كرامه او بكرامه
اذا وقفت وواجهت السلطه بالحقيقه اذا وقفت
ودافعت عن اولئك الذين وقعوا ضحايا اعتقد
ان هذه هي الكرامه دكتور فريد حافظ سعيد
جدا بوجودك في المقابله اشكر لك يعني لطفك
وانفتاحك على كل الاسئله واتمنى التوفيق
ايضا لك كباحث في هذه القضيه التي تتعلق
بالبشر اولا وبالمسلمين على وجه التحديد
في كثير من الدول في اوروبا وحتى في
الولايات المتحده
وغيرها من ونتمنى ان حتى حسن احوال
المسلمين في في البلدان الاسلاميه ايضا
قبل ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب المتابعه في
الاسبوع المقبل القاكم ان شاء الله في
حلقه جديده من المقابله دمتم بخير وفي
امان الله
شكرا دكتور
[موسيقى]